[Music]
joining us now I'm delighted he's with
us the Speaker of the House Mike Johnson
Mr speaker thank you so much for being
here now you've said that this bill is
Dead on Arrival in the house um here's
how Senator Langford reacted to your
comments on Fox and Friends watch
unfortunate that he would step out and
be able to see that right away before
obviously he had had a chance to be able
to read it as well and to be able to go
through it now we've got to actually
determine are we going to just complain
about things or we're going to actually
address and to change as many things as
we
can Mr speaker you know nothing about
what's in the bill uh 12 hours or 15
hours after it
passed we we did read through it Laura
and it did not take long to realize that
this is Dead on Arrival there's no way
we could bring this through the house
the Senate expects us to pass a a bill a
piece of legislation that you just did a
great job dismantling here what it would
do is actually further incentivize
illegal immigration it would not resolve
any of the problems not reformed in any
meaningful way the broken Asylum system
the broken parole process and all the
things that have created this
catastrophe and by the way meanwhile it
further empowers the very cabinet
secretary who designed and created this
mess they don't follow federal law why
would we do this anyway but the bill
itself would actually do more harm than
good and that's why we've said it's it's
a non-starter over here in the
house um Senator Schumer you're very
popular these days so he also had a
message for you
watch I say to speaker Johnson don't let
the 30 hard right uh people in the house
who are extreme they wanted us to
default they wanted the government not
to pay its debts they wanted us um to
the government to shut down they're
extremists and they're running your show
do the right
thing do the right thing because it's
good to give waiver waiver um discretion
to Biden and mayorca so they can just
wave the emergency anytime they feel
like it here's my message to Senator
Schumer the American people are running
the show here we're the representatives
of our constituents the American people
are on our side they recognize this
catastrophe has been disastrous for the
country every state is a border state
and everybody knows it I've been
traveling the country Laura since I
became speaker of the house I've been in
15 different states doing events it
doesn't matter whether I'm out west in
the midwest on Long Island the Deep
South South Florida it's the message is
the same it's the number one issue on
the hearts and minds of the American
people we have to solve this crisis and
I'm going to make this point again
because Senator Schumer isn't listening
apparently the president of the United
States has the authority right now to
fix this crisis he has broad executive
Authority under the under the federal
statutes and Chuck Schumer knows it and
President Biden knows it and they refuse
to use that they could stop this they
could stop the flow immediately but they
don't want to Laura and I think you
alluded to a few moments ago exactly why
that
is Mr Speaker axios reported that if the
Senate manages to pass this sweeping
National Security package and the house
passes the Israel only Bill they could
head to what is called a conference
committee in an attempt to reconcile the
differences according to one house
Republican and that translation here for
people watching is that McConnell could
try to get his open borders measure
through a conference committee how will
you prevent that maneuver from happening
we're going to use every tool in our
Arenal our Arsenal to ensure that that
does not happen and by the way in the
last half hour President Biden came out
and said that he would actually veto the
legislation the clean funding bill to
help our Ally Israel in its time of
greatest need Israel is at War U they
they are fighting for their very
existence and the president has our
troops In Harm's Way now because of the
deterrent effort against Iran and he is
suggesting that he would not send the
funding to abandon our Ally right now
that is outrageous I mean everybody who
is watching this is scratching their
heads wondering how in the world we've
gotten into this situation this
President is projecting weakness on the
world stage he is not willing to fix the
greatest crisis facing our country which
is the open border and and they're just
shown a a staggering uh level of
leadership that um that I think the
American people are going to let their
voices heard at the U lack of leadership
they're going to let their voices heard
at the election cycle that's why his
polling is so low uh this is uh the
people see what's happening here why do
you think that Langford and Schumer and
and McConnell and all of them why don't
they go back to their hometowns and
their states and have Town Halls on this
Mr Speaker what do you think the people
would say go through the specifics how
many people would still be able to come
in the thresholds the discretion all of
that and let the people voice their
opinions do you expect that to happen I
can tell you what H would happen in a
town hall anywhere in the country right
now people know the the numbers we the
official number of course is over 7
million people who've been encountered
at the border uh over 2 million
guideways that are known you know over
300 people on the terrorist watch list
that have been allowed into the country
or stopped there but we don't know how
many people have actually come over we
don't know what terrorist cells are set
up around the country fentel is a
leading cause of
death but they say this solves that Mr
Speaker they they want to sell this
political message to try to undercut
Trump and hurt you that this is going to
be solved or or or seriously ameliorated
the crisis because of this they all have
to come through the ports of Entry now
and and and all the other Provisions I
went through and your response well
you've done a good job explaining the
real details of what this actually would
accomplish and in our view it's an
immigration Bill not a border security
Bill we have to secure that border we
have an obligation to do it it's a moral
obligation it's a legal and
constitutional obligation and the White
House has done this by Design they
intentionally enacted these policies
remember we documented over 64 instances
where the president himself and his
agencies have used executive authority
to create the current situation to
create the catastrophe he could unwind
those right now the stroke of a pen
President Biden could fix this but he
does not want to do it and and I think
there's going to be a price to pay at
the
election the border patrol Union has has
said come out and said the bill is
better than the status quo does that
affect your thinking on this well I I I
think it does have something to do with
the pay structure that's in the bill I
understand that they're desperate uh for
for measures that will assist okay but
look we took 64 Republicans down to the
the Del Rio uh sector down at Eagle Pass
and early January and they told us from
their own perspective there it's as if
we're administering an open fire hydrant
we don't need buckets we need to stop
the flow we know how to do that the
president has the existing Authority
Under the statutes and he ought to use
it he could suspend all entries into the
country if he deems it to be in the
nation's interest that's exactly what
the statute says uh section 212f of the
immigration and nationality act
everybody should Google it and read it
for themselves president claims he
doesn't have that Authority even though
it's been used so many times over the
last couple of decades by previous
presidents he pretends it doesn't exist
it's it's not an excuse that is
palatable for the American people and
they're see right through this
Mr Speaker are you going to be able to
stop this bill we're going to do
everything within our power I when I say
it's Dead on Arrival I mean Dead on
Arrival um we we we're going to have to
work this every other angle that we can
and ensure that we're taking care of our
responsibilities here the house of
Republicans are dug in and ready to do
that all right Mr speaker thank you very
much hi everyone I'm Brian kilme I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now